also man kann das unterscheiden in zwei
typen von klagen die derzeit laufen das
eine ist ganz konkret gegen ganz
bestimmte anzahl von stimmen
briefwahlstimmen vor allem dass man sagt
die können nicht gewertet werden weil
dieses und jenes und sonst was daran
nicht in ordnung ist und das andere ist
dass man sagt das dürfen stimmen die
nach einem gewissen zeitpunkt
eingegangen sind überhaupt nicht mehr
gezählt werden also etwa nach dem
schluss der wahllokale eingingen
und das hat ein problem ganz praktisches
muss die erstmal unterteilen können wenn
die jetzt schon sozusagen gemischt
wurden beim auszählen aber zum teil
werden die auch noch separiert weil man
abwartet wie die gerichte dazu
entscheiden
journalisten hatten trump und sein team
mit den klagen die sie jetzt eingereicht
haben kann man das schon irgendwie
abschätzen
es gibt einen start bei dem ist es
wirklich eine heikle sache aus sicht der
demokrat nach möglicherweise spielt ja
gar keine rolle mehr das ist
pennsylvania
da gab es schon mal eine klage weil dort
dürfen alle stimmen noch bewertet werden
die am dritten elfter abgestempelt sind
die aber bis freitag eingehen und
dagegen hatten die republikaner geklagt
vom supreme courts der hat gesagt mit
den konservativen richtern
jawohl das müssen wir unterbinden das
geht gar nicht die liberalen richter
haben gesagt und natürlich jede stimme
muss zählen und ausschlaggebend war john
roberts der gesagt hat der fall geht uns
nichts an daran dass wir zu viel das
haben sie zurückgewiesen
das argument war das haben die staats
gerichte in pennsylvania entschieden
also deswegen ist das für uns egal
das könnte sich ändern wenn richterin
berit an diesem prozess teilnimmt wenn
die das wieder an sich ziehen und hier
möglicherweise eingreifen in allen
anderen fällen wusste umgeht
nachzuzählen oder bestimmte stimmen
nicht zu werten da sehe ich ehrlich
gesagt relativ wenig effekt dass es
jetzt mehr politisch insofern als tramp
damit sagt er hier ideen wahl gestohlen
und die gerichte waren halt jetzt auch
noch gegen mich aber dass das aufschlag
auf das ergebnis am ende hat selbst bei
diesem knappen ergebnissen das
halte ich für unwahrscheinlich das
verlängert den ganzen prozess also
momentan nur sie haben gerade gesagt es
ist immer noch sehr knapp es wird am
ende wahrscheinlich auch eine sehr
knappe entscheidung
aber was passiert dann sollte es
tatsächlich zu einem gleichstand kommen
und beiden und rammt gleich viele
wahlmänner und wahlfrauen für sich
gewinnen können
ja wir müssen jetzt mal abwarten in den
einzelnen staaten sind es wirklich
manchmal nur 10.000 20.000 stimmen bis
konnten etwa er wird noch nach gezählt
weil nur 0,6 prozent unterschied sind
und das ist richtig dass sie sagen da
müssen wir mal weiter denken wie ist es
wenn die nicht auf die 270 stimmen
kommen denn das muss am achten dezember
feststehen es gibt ein paar daten an die
hält sich dieser ganze prozess am 8
dezember muss klar sein welche wahlleute
aus welchem bundesstaat denn wählen
und da gibt es zwei modelle die man
kennt juristisch das eine ist es gibt
eben keine wahlleute aus bestimmten
staaten weil dann einfach kein ergebnis
feststeht oder aber das parlament im
bundesstaat schiebt sie die entscheidung
an sich und sagt wir hätten die einfach
wir sagen jetzt sozusagen der wille
unseres unbe staates da war eben so und
so das muss man gucken ist der
gouverneur in der gleichen partei findet
er das gut ist er in der anderen partei
hat er vielleicht eine konkurrierende
auswahl an wahlleuten und die kommen
dann am 14 dezember zusammen und gegen
ihr votum entweder für beiden oder
vertrag ab und diese stimmen die am 14
dezember in allen hauptstädten aller
bundesstaaten der vereinigten staaten
abgegeben wird
die werden dann nach washington
transferiert
und dort kommt am dritten januar der neu
gewählte kongress zusammen und das sieht
ja auch so aus die demokraten brachten
die mehrheit im haus die republikaner
mutmaßlich die mehrheit im senat und am
sechsten januar wird dann dort vor
beiden kammern des kongresses ausgezählt
und mike pence der ist dann nimm mich
immer noch der präsident des senats und
der muss dann schauen
hat irgendeiner 270 stimmen bekommen ist
das der fall ist er gewählt ist das
nicht der fall muss das
repräsentantenhaus am selben tag den
präsidenten wählen und der senat in
vizepräsident
das heißt am 20 januar dem tag der
inauguration werden wir so oder so einen
neuen oder auch alten us präsidenten
haben in jedem fall ist kann natürlich
noch eine verwicklungen geben jetzt
spielen was man durch das
repräsentantenhaus das muss nach
bundesstaaten abstimmen wenn die kommt
die zusammensetzung so bliebe wie sie
jetzt wer ist dann hätte so kann die
republikaner dort die mehrheit
das muss man doch prüfen wie das wie das
jetzt ist in der neukonstituierung und
angenommen die einigen sich auf
niemanden aber der senat mädchen
vizepräsident dann wird der vize
präsident zu präsident gott nie so kommt
es nicht
also diese verwicklung denen die lassen
wir uns jetzt gar nicht ein
es wird am 20 um 12 uhr mittags
irgendwie die wachablösung geben es wird
ein neuer präsident gewählt sein es wird
neuer oberkommandierender da sein und
das ist entweder der alte oder und so
sieht es derzeit aus eben ein neuer mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren